[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to channel awesome
Zorba report your source for everything
happening around the world in pop
culture and entertainment news I'm
Heather Ruth and I'm Ana Webb and I just
got beamed that was surreal like every
molecule move that was weird and this is
your news for Monday June 25th but
that's right we have a special guest on
this episode today so we're gonna go
ahead and get right in all the news we
have for this week starting with it
chapter 2 who is now added two new
actors - they're fabulous cast that's
going to be Xavier Dolan from Tom at the
farm as Adrian Moen and will bind break
from I saw the light as devs husband but
both of these character announcements
are very interesting because it
definitely seems like these additions I
mean they're going to definitely be
sticking closer to the novel and not so
much I mean there's definitely a lot of
material in the novel we've seen the
size of that monster ugly yeah short of
stuff yeah absolutely now are they still
gonna help us to have to cast the spider
that's what I've heard that spider from
was at Wawa West
I bet for you CG is the original it
these are both very darker characters
Beth's husband has some history of abuse
in a Stephen King story so it definitely
seems like these additions are
definitely going to just be a darker
addition to this old really dark tale
wonderful yeah I'm very excited to have
something like really good powerhouse
acting
to our list of already already great
actors yeah yeah so yeah I'm very
excited for it chapter two and I can't
wait for more casting now also this week
MTV announced that they are creating a
whole new sect section MTV studios and
with this new section of media which
personally I think might be leading up
to a streaming service I don't know why
it all sounds right to create a whole
new section of entertainment when you
already have like television channels
and other places toppings already yeah
so I think this is leading out to a
streaming service that's just my opinion
um and with this they announced two new
shows the first one is straight-up
ghosted great time yeah yes I mean so
MTV but it's basically kind of like a
reverse where they're seeking out people
who have ghosted them on social media
and like in case you know a ghost it
means just means that the person like
went black on them and don't talk to
them anymore I was really hoping it was
a ghost show but like with emoji the
other new show is going to be the valley
which sounds like it's just the hills
for new generations yeah but um also
they said that they're going to be
reviving a whole bunch of their other
old series so first up they're reviving
made and the real world because if MTV
reality shows they're huge and then Aeon
Flux as well which could be really cool
like yeah a moment right now popular
right now and I think it's a great idea
to market that kind of thing towards
teens and it could be really cool I'm
still gonna be animated yes okay yeah
and then lastly they're also reviving
Daria
that's like my favorite show I love that
show I don't know how to feel about this
because that the one I saw its says
called Daria and Jodie which is a weird
combo like they have some episodes
together before but it's also like they
didn't have a ton of episodes and there
they had okay chemistry but what's a
phenomenal and I would say there's
nothing they can do that our minds
haven't already made up they're gonna
happen in the future like whatever they
write is not gonna be as good as our fan
picture that we have in our so so I
don't know what to think of it I'm not
super optimistic but like we'll see
we'll see what happens where did we last
leave off with them going in there
graduating yeah they were going to
college yeah and and they had like a
little like what could happen like in
the credits but they never said it was
like absolute so so I don't know there's
stuff you can talk about with technology
and everything and people changing but
it's like I don't want to know it and
they're so well it ended so perfect do
you think they would keep with the same
animation as I think they did they'd
probably go with like more of a flash
thing you know to make it more simple
but yeah I can't feel like they'd have
to yeah because it was such an already
pretty easy style honestly what do you
think about both voice talent though
like do you think they'll have all
original pastors I don't know why they
wouldn't I mean it's like they've gotten
older but in voice acting it doesn't
really matter I mean so you can still
have like you know even if you're like
50 or 80 or whatever you can still sound
like you know whatever a slightly older
teenager you know yeah you know so like
I feel like it would work out okay but
yeah I don't know my fingers crossed but
I don't know no no well convinced quite
not yeah no I mean I know there was an
image that was released as well that was
showing the concept art of like what the
characters could look like and it looks
interesting yeah it was like from the
creators and they were they saw even had
a little bio saying hey here's what
happened like here's our official but I
mean it's still not a show sort of like
here's our fun idea of what happened to
them yeah
don't know when that's gonna come out no
idea icicle tardy enchain it's guys like
maybe she'll be amazing while being
filmed on the real world and I don't
want to tell us you didn't expect us to
do this come on Graham TV there's only
so many things you can do in
entertainment now just jump that shark
um also this week we've been on a ride
oh wow yes drama a Star Wars story so
there's been a lot of news this week
happening with Star Wars and
specifically the Star Wars story movies
so there was initially a report that was
put out that all of the Star Wars story
movies are being put on hold like don't
expect to see that Boba Fett movie cuz
it's not happening but then ABC jumped
in ABC disney jumped in and was like nah
there's there's tons of movies being
made but we just we just don't want to
tell you when they are that's what they
greeted no I mean you know but it sounds
like all of this started because there
was um of all things a Mos Eisley movie
um production which I can't think would
be cool honestly if there's like no main
character but but that Walter would say
like it should be a show I'm like I'm
that for that Mos Eisley show not for
them I mean CGP Arthur back I be doing
with
or Cushing yeah yeah it just seems like
a weird option though for all the Star
Wars stories but I mean obviously Doug
with you yeah I got to know the
backstory behind the band and why they
just play that song over and helping out
like two songs that's all they ever
played and like the other characters
like in the universe know or like that's
kind of like they like we go to this
Cantina because they know two songs yeah
yeah so that was officially like put on
hold right Hansel so then since that was
put on hold cancelled whatever then a
new site decided to just take it and run
with it what all Star Wars stories but
at this point all we know for certain is
that Rian Johnson still has his trilogy
some of the producers of Game of Thrones
also have a Star Wars series trilogy and
coming up as well the Star Wars story
movies are kind of in flux right now
although like I said ABC is saying that
they are still in production they're
still gonna happen just they're free
working how they want to market it and
should all they want to film it and kind
of propose it to the general audience
Yeah right budget cuts would be my guess
okay great I mean after solo didn't
perform as well as they thought it would
but it also makes sense people are
kidding if I'm gonna be that person for
a second people are getting Star Wars
fatigue there's so much happening right
now so I guess we'll have to wait and
see because Disney and ABC are kind of
being a child about it no we don't you
tell you about them not remake it the
last Jedi all right yes can't wait for
that this is why we can childish
responses from ABC pistolas and the
prequels are fine don't touch those but
the last Jedi we gotta do the fire put
our priorities in the right place
that's pretty much it from this week I'm
sure there's a lot of other things that
we didn't even have time to get to but I
definitely wanted to mention my animated
series of multiplex 10 is starting a
Kickstarter campaign dropping this
evening to fund five more web series
episodes and five more animated movie
reviews in case there's any I don't know
if you like movie reviews out there
anyone else watching right the worst
right up the nerve of those people and
those are going to be in addition to our
already produced nine web episodes that
are available on YouTube and online at
multiplex 10.com so if you'd like to
help fund the Kickstarter you can go to
multiplex 10.com
otherwise talk to us on social media
Heather you can find me on Twitter
Instagram or twitch where I now stream
on Tuesdays and Thursdays great Facebook
there wherever the link is and you can
find me on Facebook and everywhere else
that you need absolutely below otherwise
we will see you soon and in the meantime
can you beam us up
[Applause]
you